i've seen all of season two of the
morning show it's what we call very good
wow okay thank you
yeah uh i think that uh your uh friends
and family are gonna enjoy your work on
this season do you think
do you think i'm gonna get props on the
family whatsapp thread because that's
the real that's the real testament to
whether or not you're doing good work
i think it's for sure and i will say why
because you have scenes with both rhys
and uh jen
so i mean i think your family's gonna be
like well holy [ __ ] yeah minhash family
credibility there we go okay got it
um so before i jump into morning show
and all that stuff you're about to go on
tour yes i'm curious how long does it
actually take for you to come up with
the material that you're gonna do on a
tour like this yeah so so i'm about to
go on tour for the king's jester my last
comedy special was called homecoming
king that came out in 2017.
i've been writing this show for the past
three years and it was ready to go
before the pandemic and then obviously
things updated and happened during the
pandemic so i continued to write over
the past year year and a half um so this
show's been four years in the making and
um you know to me it really is
the next evolution of of the things that
have happened to me not only in my life
um but to my family and so if if you've
been to my shows before you know there's
there's comedy there's storytelling
there's parts that make you cry
and there's a bunch of screens and kind
of theater theatrics that happen behind
behind me as well so i'm really excited
to kind of have a show um a touring show
you know back on the road again it'll be
really fun
you're doing i think five nights in
boston how much pressure do you feel in
your to like make sure each night is
maybe a little different or like i mean
can you sort of talk about that totally
so there you know again it's the show
itself
is quite similar yes even though it is a
a stand-up show it leans more towards
theatrical storytelling there's lighting
cues there's graphics cues there's a
there's an actual stage in stage design
and lighting design that all comes
together and um we have an incredible
team aaron ryan and jaffee weidman who
have done incredible work on broadway
are now coming into the space and the
exciting part is is is those broadway
theatrical elements meeting the
the
sort of live in the room stand-up
storytelling elements and so when i'm in
boston you know there's definitely going
to be some material that's topical in
nature and then we'll pivot into kind of
stuff that's a little bit more evergreen
and and true to the show um that's the
fun part it's doing that dance and i
can't wait to come to boston
yeah that's also a great town to do any
but that that's a whole different thing
so it's one of the best comedy cities in
the country by the way it's great yeah
boston's fantastic um so jumping into
the show
when you were approached for them for
getting involved in this how much did
they sort of tell you about the arc of
what your character would be doing and
how much are you like oh this show is
awesome whatever you need me to do yeah
so
the when i actually got the materials
one of the audition pieces that i got
was the first scene that you see eric in
i had to do a song and dance number and
so my agent calls me it was the wedding
of my
sorry it was the weekend of my sister's
wedding and so i get i get an email from
my agent um and we're getting ready to
go to the reception dinner and he goes
hey listen man i think you'd be perfect
for this i think you should put yourself
on tape and i go who am i going to
record lines with my wife said no my mom
has always wanted to join sag-aftra so
she was down to do he was trying to do
the audition so i straight up did my
song and dance number that you see in
season two of the morning show with
reese i did that with my mom and i i
guess they found it endearing and cute
and and mimi and carrie at the show um
reached out and said hey we'd love for
you to be a part of the show and i
didn't know anything else about eric's
arc on the show they just in the
character description said he's a young
charismatic
uh tv host that comes in to join the
morning show and and then um
you know
problems ensue i didn't know what those
problems would be
um what do you like uh what do you think
might surprise people to learn about the
making of the morning show like the
behind the scenes not the covet of it
all because obviously the covet sucks
and it's you know but i'm just curious
about the other stuff sure i think one
of the things that's most impressive
about the show is i've never been on a
production with
this level of scale or grand grandeur
and you see that translate through the
screen i mean like no expense is spared
there's a scene that you'll see in
season two that takes place during new
year's
they recreated times square just for the
scene
that me and reese are doing when we're
bringing in the ball drop and and when i
was looking around uh you know that day
with all the extras all the green screen
all just the practical things that they
had to build in california to recreate
new york city it's just it's just an
incredible feat they they really spare
no expense and and what uh the team at
apple and the morning show would do to
recreate
that entire world is pretty incredible
it's truly incredible yeah um uh apple
i've said this to other people apple
doesn't have as much content as say
netflix but the stuff they make is very
very good yeah there's two things that i
think people are going to really see
when you see it through the actual
screen just scale and quality the scale
and scope of the vision like what you're
actually putting on camera and then the
actual just intrinsic quality of the
cinematography the work
all the stuff that you see in set design
lighting design all of that stuff is
really really incredible it's why their
shows are so great
uh this season has really good story
lines for all the characters uh besides
have you seen the episodes yet i've seen
some of them i haven't seen all of them
got it oh i was gonna see you've seen
all the way you've seen all the way to
ten yeah i saw the whole season
that's crazy because there's still
because you know they're still making
they're still like mixing and editing
some of the episodes that's why some of
the episodes i saw were very uh they're
like episode 7 or 8 was um i'm going to
use the term rough in terms of seeing
the green screen and yeah
right they haven't popped stuff in yet
yeah yeah i mean i mean i understand
what they're going for that i mean the
performances in the storyline are so
good it makes no difference that you're
seeing in a rougher stage yeah and one
of the things that i think is is really
amazing
i actually think based on the script
season two is going to be much better
than season one
and the depth in the run runway room
that they gave steve carell
um
jen reese karen pittman is incredible in
the show karen is such a a force on the
show desean it really is great and greta
lee is fantastic on the show as well so
it's the fact that you have such a
sprawling cast of incredible actors and
actresses and everybody's you know
firing on all cylinders i was really
lucky to be a part of it
yeah that that's the thing that i
commend uh this season on is that all
the characters have arcs that feel
believable for the storyline sure
um i'll ask you this so corey uh played
by billy
do you view him as a good person
a bad person or it depends on the day of
the week yeah so it's interesting
corey is no different than any other
character on the show one of the central
themes and takeaways of the show for me
is
everybody thinks they're the protagonist
and hero of their own story
corey fundamentally believes he is a
good person and he is trying to do good
things in the world
every character on that show is saying
how do i become an ethical person in a
fundamentally unethical world
and um
the way you see that unfold in every
character's actions is really
interesting that's why i love i love
that this show in season two especially
explores the grays and nuances of life
and and i'm just saying this is a father
of two and as a husband it is the grays
and the nuances of life where that is
where all the details are that is the
thing that really tests your humanity
and your ethics
i agree gotta go thank you so much for
your time and good luck with your
families what app um you know
uh when they contact you i'll let you
know what they say i'm gonna i'm gonna
post the screen grabs they'll they'll
verify whether your assessment was right
or not
i have one last question for you did did
the song and dance number hit
how is how is my family in india going
to respond
oh um they're going to be i told you you
can't go when you're doing something
with rhys
it doesn't matter what you're doing
because everyone is i'm being honest
like everyone's going to be looking at
the two of you together and you guys are
great and like look this this show is
what we call as i said at the beginning
it's very very good
great that's awesome thank you man cool
have a great day yeah man be well peace